what i want to do in this video is prove
that parallel lines have the same slope
so let's draw some parallel lines here
so that's one line
and then let me draw another line that
is parallel to that i'm claiming that
these are parallel lines
and now i'm going to draw some
transversals here so first let me draw a
horizontal transversal
so just like that and then let me do a
vertical transversal
so
just like that
and i'm assuming that the green one is
horizontal and the blue one is vertical
so we assume that they are perpendicular
to each other that these intersect at
right angles
and from this i'm going to figure out
i'm going to use i'm going to use some
parallel line angle properties to
establish that this triangle and this
triangle are similar and then use that
to establish that that both of these
lines both of these yellow lines have
the same slope
so actually let me label some points
here so let's call that point a
point b
point
c
point
d
and point
e
so
let's see
first of all we know that angle c e d is
going to be congruent to angle a b a e b
because they're both right angles so
that's a right angle and then that is a
right angle right over there
we also know some things about
corresponding angles for a transverse
where transversal intersects parallel
lines
this angle
corresponds to this angle if we look at
the blue transversal as it intersects
those two lines and so they're going to
be they're going to have the same
measure they're going to be congruent
now this angle on one side of this point
b is going to also be congruent to that
because they are vertical angles and
we've seen that multiple times before
and so we know that this angle angle a b
e is congruent to angle e c d sometimes
this is called alternate interior angles
of a transversal and parallel lines
well if you look at triangle c e d and
triangle a b e we see they already have
two angles in common so if they have two
angles in common well the their third
angle has to be in common
so
because this third angle is just going
to be 180 minus these other two and so
this third angle is just going to be 180
minus this the other two and so just
like that we notice we have all three
angles are the same in both of these
triangles or they're not all the same
but all of the corresponding angles i
should say are the same angle angle
this blue angle is has the same measure
as this as this blue angle this magenta
angle has the same measure as this
magenta angle and then the other angles
are right angles these are right
triangles here so we could say
triangle aeb
triangle a
e
b
is similar
similar
similar
to
triangle
d
e
c triangle d
e c by and we could say by
angle angle angle all the corresponding
angles are congruent so we are dealing
with similar triangles and so we know
similar triangles the ratio of
corresponding sides are going to be the
same so we could say that the ratio of
let's say the ratio of b
e
the ratio of b e let me write this down
this is this side right over here the
ratio of b
e
to a e
to a e
to a e
is going to be equal to
so that side over that side well what is
the corresponding side the corresponding
side to be is side ce
so that's going to be the same as the
ratio between c e
and d e
and
d e and this just comes out of similar
the similarity of the triangles
c e
to
d e
so once again once we establish these
triangles are similar we can say the
ratio of corresponding sides are going
to be the same
now what is
what is the ratio between b e and a e
the ratio between b e
and a e
well that is the slope of this top line
right over here we could say that's the
slope of line
a b
slope
slope
of
line
connecting
connecting
a
to
b or actually let me just use i could
write it like this that is slope of
slope of
a
slope of line a b remember slope is when
you're going from a to b
it's change in y
over change in x so when you're going
from a to b your change in x is a e and
your change in y
is be or eb however you want to refer to
it so this right over here is change in
y
and this over here is change in x
well now let's look at this second
expression right over here c e over d e
c e over d e
well now this is going to be change in y
over change in x between point c and d
so this is this right over here this is
a slope
of line
of line cd
and so just like that by establishing
similarity
we were able to see the ratio of
corresponding sides are congruent which
shows us that the slopes of these two
lines are going to be the same and we
are done